roses are red violets are blue but
really how long they last is up to you
fresh flowers you know they're beautiful
but they don't last too long so we asked
the experts for tricks of the trade
when it comes to keeping flowers fresh
who better to consult than the experts
at mgm who take care of the bellagio's
conservatory the conservatory has about
8 000
plants that are there we have about
5 000
fresh cut flowers that are put in the
little flower children so what's the key
to keeping these blooms from wilting you
need to change out the water every
couple days
you need to do a new cut on the flower
stem and actually you want to do
as much of an angled cut as possible
because that increases the surface area
that they can
suck up the water
you want to keep it out of drafts you
want to keep it away from heat sources
also get rid of any excess leaves in the
vase that mucks up the water jessica
walker is the director of horticulture
and floral at mgm resorts she says
there's a couple other tricks that work
you've heard bleach you've heard sugar
you've heard copper pennies aspirin like
all of that stuff there's some truth to
all of it
you know you want the water a little bit
acidic you want sugar
um a little sugar to help the flowers
bloom
the uh the aspirin also helps with like
the acidifier
um bleach does like the disinfectant and
not all flowers are created equal a lot
of people like to buy them open but when
you're buying them open they're at the
end of their life span so you want to
buy a flower that's actually closed
walker says if you do everything right
you should get about a week out of roses
but remember there are other options too
for all the gentlemen out there or
partners out there like it doesn't have
to be roses
well there you go and hector even showed
us some options yeah lilies daisies
dandelions not dandelions don't do
gotcha it's better than nothing though i
suppose